this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer richard wakeling
fifa 22 opens with a lavish cut scene
that feels like it has more style than
substance but it also ushers in what
feels like a new era for the series
star studied cutscene aside ea's latest
entry makes the most of next-gen
technology and combines it with a shift
in tempo to significantly improve the
on-pitch action
[Music]
the opening tutorial that follows the
intro cutscene serves to show off one
new feature the ability to switch to a
specific defender by pressing in both
thumbsticks player switching has been
overly cumbersome in the past so it's
nice to have a reliable way to take
control of the best place player without
having to scroll through each
backtracking defender until the cursor
lands on the right one
the only problem with this is it's still
not quite fast enough in the most hectic
moments and ends up feeling redundant as
a result fifa 22 doesn't introduce any
mechanical additions beyond this but
that doesn't mean it rests on its
laurels and fails to move the series
forward instead it's the inclusion of
innovative new technology and a more
considered pace that iterates and
improves on the series's core gameplay
hypermotion is a fancy marketing term
for this new technology but it's more
than just simple jargon by using xsense
mod cap suits hyper motion allows the
developers to use motion capture on all
22 footballers in a real-life match by
capturing a full 11v11 match all of the
authentic movement is implemented and
immediately palpable in fifa 22 both at
an individual and team level the game
features a plethora of new animations
that impact every phase of a 90 minute
match you'll see players take additional
touches when controlling the ball to
create an extra yard of space or to
pluck a high pass out of the sky before
positioning their body to ping a
diagonal ball to the opposite wing
forwards will reduce their stride and
take smaller steps before hitting a shot
on goal and opponents will outmaneuver
each other in an attempt to dominate
their aerial duel all of this not only
makes each moment and interaction look
as believable as the games we watch on
tv and in stadiums every week but it
also ensures that fifa 22 feels more
fluid by having each animation naturally
flow into the next without any
noticeable seams in between as a result
fifa 22 is a noticeably slower game than
its predecessor it's not quite as
responsive but it doesn't need to be
because you're not zipping the ball
around at 100 miles per hour matches in
fifa 21 often resembled the back and
forth nature of basketball games with
the ball rapidly moving from one penalty
box to the next there isn't a lack of
goals in this year's game they're just
created through slick passing moves
rather than exploiting the fastest
player on the pitch
pace is still a valuable asset yet it's
not the be-all and end-all of your
attacking threat fifa is a better and
more balanced game when speed doesn't
dominate the meta as it has in past
years harry kane might be one of the
best strikers in the world with his 90
rating reflecting that but finding
anyone who actually used him on ultimate
team in fifa 21 is a challenge
that shouldn't be the case in fifa 22 as
slower strikers are now viable options
to lead your front line it's more
accurate to real-life football and more
satisfying as a result you're rewarded
for being patient and methodical in your
build up play but crosses are now a
useful tactic if you have a striker
who's strong in the air and adept at
peeling off their marker you're not
outmatched in defense either though
hyper motion also has a tangible effect
on team shape with players able to move
as one cohesive unit the backline will
maintain its shape while holding
midfielders keep their position in front
of the defensive unit making you tougher
to break down if you opt to play this
way with new more varied tackling
animations plus the fact that you're
more likely to come away with the ball
after a successful tackle defending can
be just as enjoyable as attacking
goalkeepers aren't a liability behind
you either which helps they're not
infallible but they pull off a more
expansive array of saves and aren't so
easily beaten by shots across the face
of goal finesse shots from outside the
box do give them some issues however and
could deal with a tweak so they're not
quite as effective
in terms of game modes fifa 22 has taken
a page out of pez's book and added a
couple of sentences of its own you're
now able to create your own team in
career mode from customizing the kits
and the stadium to deciding whether your
team of randomly generated players is
more youthful or experienced you can
replace an existing team in any division
and choose your overall star rating
before tweaking the board's expectations
to your liking it's a neat idea that
feels long overdue considering how long
master league's been around it's just
difficult to enjoy a squad of nobodies
compared to taking over a real club with
household names
volta football meanwhile is getting
close to resembling the original fifa
streak moving further away from realism
each player now has one of three
supernatural abilities they can unleash
during a match to tap into the mode's
arcade sensibilities power strike means
your shots are super powered pure pace
gives you a boost of turbo speed and
aggressive tackle lets you plow through
opponents to win back a ball with
relative ease it's not quite as over the
top as fifa street but it's edging
closer there's no story this time either
so you're left to either play games
against the ai to earn xp and unlock
customization options or play with other
people in volta squads the latter is
better with friends unless you enjoy
playing with a bunch of strangers who
refuse to pass the ball to anyone ever
walter's best new edition is only
available on the weekends for some
confounding reason volta arcade
introduces a variety of party minigames
that revolve around a particular skill
lava disco for instance tasks you with
capturing white tiles on a dance floor
by dribbling through them there's also
dodgeball foot tennis and plenty more of
these frantic party games it's just
baffling that you can only play them
during the weekend
pro clubs has also received some notable
new additions after years of neglect
none of it is groundbreaking but a
slightly altered progression system that
includes perks and player archetypes
makes it easier to build a player that's
unique to you and you can finally play
as a woman this year too
the other changes are cosmetic letting
you customize your team's home stadium
with tifos gold songs crowd chance and
more
ultimate team will still be the major
time sink for most players though and in
fifa 22 ea's made a few incremental
changes to its successful formula the
framework for division rivals has been
altered to make it more accessible for
players of all skill levels the rewards
you receive aren't quite as good as
previous years which could drive players
to the game's micro transactions but a
forgiving checkpoint system ensures that
you can't lose progression after
reaching a reward tier however it is
deflating that you don't earn instant
rewards for gaining promotion playing
foot champions is still the best way to
earn the biggest rewards and has been
tweaked this year too
after qualifying for [ __ ] champions via
division rivals you're placed into a new
playoff stage that you can play anytime
throughout the week rather than having
to rack up wins you earn 4 points for
each win and 1 point for each loss
eight points are enough to reach the
first reward tier but you need 24 points
from nine matches in order to qualify
for the finals once you've done that it
reverts back to the old weekend league
format except it still uses the same
point system as the playoffs and there's
only a 20 match limit compared to the
previous 30. this makes for champions
easier to digest and alleviates a lot of
the stress since you're still making
progress even if you lose
pay to win microtransactions are still
front and center through our ultimate
team despite mounting pressure from
regulators and it's difficult to ignore
fifa 22 dolls out a lot of rewards
without forcing you to spend a penny but
you're unlikely to see a lot of the
players especially the icons without
filling up ea's pockets amid a time
preview packs let you check what's
inside a pack before buying but this
only applies to a single pack that
refreshes once every 24 hours this year
in particular it feels like the
developers are trying to make ultimate
team fairer and less exploitative but
the microtransactions aren't going away
anytime soon unless forced to by law
fifa 22 is a fantastic football game
once you step out onto the pitch with a
realistic and methodical style that
rewards passing and vision over the
exploitation of cheap pace merchants off
the pitch there isn't anything quite as
impactful but minor changes and new
additions make game modes like vaulter
and career mode more fun to play an
ultimate team is a more accessible
experience that's nonetheless still
burdened by its micro transactions there
are few better feelings in sports games
than being able to string together an
aesthetically pleasing passing move that
ends with the ball in the back of the
net though and for that reason fifa 22
is a worthwhile upgrade
[Music]